DAVID STANKE: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't catch
Develop, Deploy, and Debug
Using Google Cloud
Developer Tools,
then stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cloud computing
platforms are built
on some of the most exciting,
sophisticated technology
in the world.
But what makes the
Cloud truly valuable
is the amazing software that
you build and run on it.
Let's take a look
at how Google Cloud
Platform helps you develop,
deploy, and debug in the Cloud.
GCP leverages Google's
deep expertise
in building world-class
software to bring you
an amazing development
environment.
As a developer, you
need actionable insights
throughout the entire
software lifecycle and tools
to integrate from
each phase to the next
so you can continuously
iterate and improve
on your applications.
Let's start with the code.
Google's Cloud
Source Repositories
is enterprise-grade Git
hosting for private repos.
It's architected to scale
up to massive code bases
and provides extremely
high availability.
And it provides
security intelligence
to prevent sensitive
data, like access keys,
from ever landing in your repo.
CSR also comes with code search.
You can search
across multiple repos
at once, using advanced syntax
like regular expressions.
Code search is built
on the same technology
as Google's famous
search engine,
so it truly understands code.
Entities like classes,
functions, and fields
are indexed and displayed
as real-time suggestions
for fast navigation.
Next, deploying applications--
Cloud Source Repositories
is pre-integrated with
Cloud Build, Google Cloud's
fully-managed CI/CD platform.
Use Cloud Build to compile,
test, package, and deploy
your code to any
Google Cloud Runtime,
including Compute Engine,
Kubernetes Engine,
and Cloud Run.
But maybe not everything
should get deployed.
How can you be sure that
what you're running is safe?
Google's got your
back with services
that actively detect
software vulnerabilities
in every artifact you store
in your private Container
Registry.
When you pair
vulnerability scanning
with binary authorization
for Kubernetes Engine,
you'll have a
powerful gatekeeper
protecting your infrastructure.
Only artifacts that have been
given a clean bill of health
will have permission
to run on your cluster.
Finally, debugging
a running system--
Cloud Source Repositories
works with Stackdriver
to unlock your
developer superpowers.
Are you trying to wrangle
a hard-to-reproduce bug?
With the Stackdriver
Debugger, you
can attach break points at
specific points in your code
or capture a complete
snapshot of application state
to find that needle
in the haystack.
Amazingly, all of this
happens without any need
to revise or redeploy
your code and
with no appreciable
performance impact.
Use these diagnostic tools
on the fly, in real time,
for production workloads.
This was just a taste of the
powerful developer experience
on Google Cloud Platform.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]